Esta es la pregunta del millón de dólares: ¿Puede
sobrevivir la economía de Ucrania a una invasión
rusa? Dicho de otra forma ¿Cómo afectaría una
invasión rusa a los ucranianos que viven en
los territorios no ocupados? ¿Podrían mantener
sus empresas o se verían relegados a subsistir?
Me explico: en estos momentos, todas las opciones
están abiertas. Putin no se ha limitado a invadir
el Este de Ucrania sino que ha llegado hasta
la capital: KIEV ¿Qué significa esto? ¡No lo
sabemos! Puede que Rusia y Ucrania terminen en
una guerra abierta que se prolongaría durante
años. O tal vez negocien un alto el fuego.
Aquí en VisualPolitik no tenemos una bola de
cristal PERO tenemos otra cosa: mucha memoria.
Porque sí, mis queridos amigos de la comunidad
Visualpolitik, existe un precedente muy
parecido a Ucrania. Un país que también
ha sido invadido por Putin ¿De qué país
estamos hablando? ¡Exacto! de Georgia.
No, no me refiero al estado de Estados Unidos sino
al país. Georgia, con capital en TIFLIS ¿Significa
esto que los ucranianos van a correr la misma
suerte que los georgianos? No. Pero nadie puede
negar que hay un montón de similitudes. Además,
Georgia puede enseñar un montón de lecciones.
Si sois nómadas digitales o estáis
interesados en este estilo de vida,
seguramente hayáis oído mencionar este país miles
de veces. Se trata de uno de los destinos de moda
para pequeños emprendedores y nómadas digitales. Y
os tengo que confesar que aquí, en VisualPolitik,
tenemos un cariño especial a este país ¿Por qué?
Pues porque nuestro primer vídeo viral fue un
vídeo que dedicamos a Georgia. Corría el año 2016,
cuando todavía no teníamos ni 1000 suscriptores.
Quien nos iba a decir entonces que la comunidad de
VisualPolitik iba a ser tan grande y que… ¡Hasta
tendríamos camisetas! Por cierto ¿Queréis haceros
con nuestro merchandising exclusivo? ¡Pues no está
a la venta! La única forma de conseguirlo
es entrando en nuestro Patreon. Vamos,
que estas camisetas son exclusivas de verdad.
Y, por cierto, todos los diseños están hechos
por nosotros. Dicho de otra forma: si entráis a
formar parte del Patreon de VisualPolitik no sólo
vais a ayudar a que este proyecto siga adelante
con todo la independencia y el rigor que tanto
os gusta. Además accederéis a merchandising
realmente exclusivo… y nuestra newsletter de
análisis político que es un auténtico lujazo.
Pero volvamos con nuestra historia de hoy.
Lo cierto es que Georgia es uno de los países más
interesantes del mundo. Especialmente
por este señor que véis en pantalla.
Os presento al ex presidente de Georgia, MIKHAIL
SAAKASHVILI. Si este hombre hubiera nacido en San
Francisco, os aseguro que tendría, por lo menos,
3 series en Netflix. Creo que es el único político
de la historia que puede presumir de haber ocupado
cargos de responsabilidad en dos países distintos:
uno es Georgia y... ¿El otro? Uno, dos, tres...
¡Exacto! ¡Ucrania! Tras gobernar Ucrania,
Sakaashvili consiguió la ciudadanía ucraniana y
llegó a ser Gobernador de la región de Odessa.
Absolutamente todo en la vida de este hombre es
digno de película. Podrá gustaros más o menos pero
nadie puede negar que es un personaje único en la
historia. Un señor que levanta pasiones y odios
¿Y quién es su mayor hater? ¡Exacto! Vladimir
Putin. Y ojo, porque hablamos de odio de verdad.
Atentos porque esto es una declaración textual.
“Algún día colgaré a Saakashvili de las pelotas”
--Vladimir Putin en 2008
Ufff! Si Putin te dice eso... ya puedes asustarte.
Y diréis ¿Por que tanto odio? Pues lo cierto es
que la quinta parte del territorio de Georgia
está ocupado por Rusia. Y así lleva desde
el año 2008 cuando estalló la guerra de
Georgia. Habéis oído bien: podríamos decir
que Georgia es una Ucrania en miniatura.
Así que la pregunta es ¿Por que hay tantos
nómadas digitales que se marchan a vivir a
un país invadido? ¿Ha sobrevivido Georgia
a la invasión rusa? ¿Qué lecciones pueden
aprender los ucranianos de esta historia?
¿Qué errores ha cometido Georgia? Hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
(LA ALDEA DE BORAT)
Ya lo hemos dicho:
si eres un nómada digital, probablemente hayas
oído hablar de Georgia o incluso estés ahí en
estos momentos. Georgia sigue siendo un país
pobre pero, a la vez, han llegado a pedir entrar
en la Unión Europea. Todo esto es una historia
de cuento de hadas si tenemos en cuenta que
hace veinte años, Georgia era... ¿Cómo decirlo?
¿Habéis visto “Borat”? Pues, al lado de Georgia,
la aldea de Borat parecería Manhattan. Este país
era la cristalización de todos los estereotipos
que tengáis en la cabeza de una república
ex soviética: mafias, corrupción y pobreza.
Durante la guerra fría, Georgia era una república
dentro de la Unión Soviética. En 1991 declararon
la independencia y entraron en guerra con Moscú.
Al igual que está ocurriendo en Ucrania, Georgia
tiene dos provincias cuya población se siente más
rusa que ucraniana. Hablamos de OSETIA DEL SUR
y ABJASIA. Desde 1992, son dos regiones de esas
que aparecen sombreadas con rayitas en los mapas.
Y diréis ¿Qué ha pasado en el resto
del país? Pues, para ser honestos,
nada bueno. Muchos de vosotros pensaríais que
el fin del comunismo fueron buenas noticias para
todos los que vivían en la URSS. Sin embargo,
Georgia es uno de los casos donde no fue así.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en sólo 10 años, el
PIB de Georgia cayó a menos de la mitad. Es más,
este país sigue sufriendo una pérdida de población
brutal. En 1989, Georgia tenía cerca de 5 millones
de habitantes. Ahora están en 3,7 millones de
personas. Y diréis ¿Pero cómo es posible que
las cosas vayan tan mal por este lugar? Pensadlo
bien: en los años 90, Georgia se convirtió en el
campo de cultivo perfecto para mafias y políticos
corruptos ¡Pero no sólo eso! La poca industria
que había en el país venía desde Moscú. Una vez
se independizaron, todas las fábricas cerraron.
Para que os hagáis una idea, durante los 90, la
principal exportación georgiana era la chatarra
que habían dejado los soviéticos en las fábricas
siderúrgicas... Sí, habéis oído bien: la principal
exportación de Georgia eran los trozos de metal
que quedaban de las fábricas que se acababan de
cerrar. Con esto ya os podéis imaginar cómo
estaba el país. Por otra parte, tampoco es
nada que os sorprenda. Hablamos de la región del
Cáucaso: todos los países y regiones de esta zona
están igual o peor. Por esta zona está Azerbaiyán,
Armenia, Chechenia... ¡Vamos! Que estamos hablando
de una de las zonas más oscuras del planeta.
Sin embargo, el destino de Georgia cambió
para siempre en el año 2003 ¿Qué ocurrió en
este momento? Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
(LA REVOLUCIÓN DE LAS ROSAS)
Hay momentos en la historia en los que una persona
lo cambia todo. Este es uno de esos casos. Y sí,
la persona es Mikhail Sakaashvili. Alguno
dirá que este vídeo es una alabanza y loa a
la figura de este hombre. Pero, dejando a un lado
la opinión que se pueda tener sobre este hombre,
nadie puede negar que lo ha vivido TODO.
Objetivamente, este señor ha cambiado
completamente la historia de su país. Y os lo
digo en serio: en VisualPolitik hemos analizado
un montón de países y figuras políticas: la vida
de Saakashvili es una película. En el vídeo de
hoy sólo vamos a contar una pequeña parte. En
el año 2003, Mikhail Saakashvili era un abogado
que había estudiado en Estados Unidos. Ahí se
convirtió en el mayor defensor de Occidente
y el libre mercado. Sí, mis queridos amigos
liberales y libertarios que veis este canal:
si hay un héroe del estado mínimo y el
liberalismo, ese no es otro que Saakashvili.
En 2003 lideró lo que podríamos llamar la
revolución liberal más exitosa de los últimos
100 años: La revolución de las rosas. Vale, hay
que reconocer una cosa: la forma en la que llegó
al poder no fue lo más democrática del mundo. Pero
seamos claros, recordad que Georgia era algo así
como la aldea de Borat pero aún peor. En cualquier
caso, Saakashvili llegó el poder con una promesa:
convertir a Georgia en el paraíso del libre
mercado. Eso significa lucha contra la corrupción,
impuestos bajos y acuerdos de libre comercio con
todo el mundo. Para que os hagáis una idea, sus
reformas fueron tan radicales que incluso el Fondo
Monetario Internacional dejó de prestar dinero al
país. Y diréis ¿Por qué? Pues porque pensaban que,
con unos impuestos tan bajos, sería incapaz de
devolver los préstamos. Sin embargo... ¿Adivináis
que es lo que pasó? Atentos a esta gráfica.
Aquí lo tenéis: Georgia tiene uno de los sistemas
fiscales más minimalistas del mundo ¿Recordáis
nuestro vídeo de Estonia? Pues Georgia sigue
un modelo casi idéntico. A eso hay que sumarle
los acuerdos de libre comercio y la limpieza del
estado. Para que os hagáis una idea, Saakashvili
llegó a despedir a más de 16.000 policías
corruptos en los primeros años de su mandato.
Ya sé lo que estaréis pensando: suena como el
sueño de VisualPolitik ¿Verdad? Pues sí. Por
supuesto que a muchos os parecerá un programa
horrible de gobierno. Pero lo cierto es que los
datos hablan por sí solos. Entre 2004 y 2007,
el PIB de Georgia creció un 35%. Y la inversión
internacional se volcó en el país. Por poner un
ejemplo, fue en el año 2007 cuando Ferrero, la
marca que fabrica la NUTELLA (o, como lo conocemos
en España, NOCILLA), abrió una planta en el país
para poder procesar las avellanas. Y es que sí,
una de las principales exportaciones de Georgia
son los frutos secos. Eso y el vino. Georgia es
conocida como el lugar donde nació el vino. Así
que, en pocos años, este país se dedicó a exportar
avellanas y vino como si no hubiera mañana.
¡Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando! Eso es sector
primario ¿Dónde está la industria? Pues sí,
tenéis razón. Pero pensad que Georgia venía
de ser la aldea de Borat. Lo importante es
que el país estaba en la senda correcta. Era la
estrella del cáucaso. Y entonces... es cuando
ocurrió la desgracia. Atentos.
(LAS PRIMERAS VÍCTIMAS DE PUTIN)
Otra de las promesas de Saakashvili al llegar
al poder fue la reunificación nacional. A los
georgianos no les hacía nada de gracia
tener a dos provincias que, de facto,
eran independientes. Puede sonar un poco
raro pero, pese a ser un país tan pequeño,
con menos de 4 millones de habitantes, Georgia
tiene varios idiomas y etnias distintas. Y hay
dos regiones donde el georgiano no lo quieren
ver ni en pintura: OSETIA DEL SUR y ABJASIA.
¿Y qué tienen en común estas regiones?
Pues aparte de no tener mucha simpatía
por Georgia... tienen un enorme
cariño por... ¡La madre Rusia!
¡Exacto! Esta historia os resulta familiar.
Es algo casi idéntico al Dombás o a Crimea
¡Pero no sólo eso! Como ya os podéis imaginar,
es difícil declarar tu amor eterno por el libre
mercado y por Occidente sin enfadar a Rusia.
Especialmente cuando Saakashvili declaró su
interés explícito por entrar en la OTAN. Al
igual que ha ocurrido con Ucrania, el primer
ataque de Putin vino por la cartera. En 2006,
Rusia ordenó un boicot comercial contra Georgia.
¿Y qué vino después de la cartera?
¡Exacto! El ataque militar.
Rusia y Georgia chocan por una región separatista
Exacto! En el año 2008, un grupo de separatistas
de Osetia del Sur pusieron una bomba a un
grupo de soldados georgianos. Georgia había
intentado negociar una solución territorial
que permitiera que las regiones rebeldes
aceptasen formar parte de Georgia. Pero las
negociaciones no habían funcionado. Y esta
atentado fue la gota que colmó el vaso. Primero
el ejército georgiano invadió Osetia del Sur.
Después Rusia apoyó a los osetios del Sur.
Y así es como estalló una guerra entre Rusia
y Georgia.
Al
igual que la guerra de Ucrania, Rusia también
llegó hasta la capital de Georgia. De hecho,
al igual que ha ocurrido en Kiev, los rusos
también bombardearon el aeropuerto de Tiflis
¡No sólo eso! En sólo 12 días Rusia ocupó
casi todo el país, incluídas las partes con
población antirusa. Sí, esto es lo mismo
que está pasando ahora mismo en Ucrania…
Con una diferencia ¡Los Georgianos estaban
en una situación mucho peor! Pensadlo bien:
el ejército de Ucrania ha tenido casi 8 años
para prepararse para una invasión. Lo hemos
contado ya en muchos vídeos de VisualPolitik.
Sin embargo, Georgia es un país más pequeño,
con menos ejército y, en definitiva,
más fácil de conquistar. Invadir toda
Ucrania llevaría mucho más de 12 días.
En cualquier caso ¿Qué pasó en Georgia?
Pues en este caso, Francia medió para negociar
un alto el fuego. Rusia consiguió lo que quería:
el control de ABJASIA y OSETIA DEL NORTE. A
cambio, retiraron las tropas del resto de Georgia.
¿Conclusión? ¿Cuál es la
situación en Georgia hoy en día?
Pues lo que véis en el mapa: en los mapamundis de
Rusia, Abjasia y Osetia del Sur son dos repúblicas
independientes. Sin embargo, ningún otro país los
reconoce como tal. Así que, en los mapamundis del
resto del mundo, son dos territorios sombreados
con rayitas. Y, a efectos prácticos, estas dos
repúblicas actúan como dos provincias rusas.
Incluso usan el rublo como moneda de curso legal.
En otras palabras: parece muy razonable pensar
que DONESK y LUHANSK corran la misma suerte. Y,
creedme, no os gustaría vivir por estas zonas.
La pregunta es ¿Qué ha pasado en el resto de
Georgia? ¿Han conseguido seguir con su
vida pese a la guerra con Rusia? Pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
(ENTRE RUSIA Y OCCIDENTE)
En el año 2013 Sakaashvili perdió las elecciones
¿Y quién diríais que le sucedió? Pues atentos,
porque esta es una historia de personajes, cuando
menos pintorescos. El sucesor de Saakashvili fue
este otro señor que véis en pantalla.
Hablamos de BIDZINA IVANISHVILI, también
conocido con el apodo de “BORIS”. Este buen señor
hizo una auténtica fortuna vendiendo ordenadores
en Rusia durante los años 90. Y diréis ¿Cómo de
grande es su fortuna? Pues se calcula que este
hombre tiene una suma de dinero equivalente a
la tercera parte de todo el PIB de Georgia. Sí,
habéis oído bien. Y después de haber hecho
tantísimo dinero en Rusia, volvió a su Georgia
natal para probar suerte en la política. En
2012 creó su propio partido al que llamó “EL
SUEÑO GEORGIANO”. Y, como os podéis imaginar,
con tantísimo dinero para campaña electoral,
el Sueño Georgiano arrasó en las elecciones del
año siguiente ¡Pero no sólo eso! Tras ganar las
elecciones, Saakashvili fue exiliado y perdió la
nacionalidad. (Paréntesis: Saakashvili es uno de
los pocos ejemplos de una persona que ha llegado a
ser, técnicamente, apátrida: es decir, que durante
un par de años no tuvo ninguna nacionalidad...
pero eso es otra historia para otro vídeo).
En cualquier caso, desde el año 2013, el partido
de Ivanishvili ha dominado la política georgiana.
Y diréis ¿Qué ideología tiene este partido? Pues,
como os podéis imaginar, Sueño Georgiano es todo
lo prorruso que puede ser un partido en Georgia.
Es decir, no mucho. Como os podéis imaginar,
la mayoría de los Georgianos no quieren ver a
Rusia ni en pintura. No deja de ser el país con
el que todavía siguen en guerra. Sin embargo,
Ivanishvili es lo suficientemente prorruso
como para lograr cosas como esta.
Rusia lista para volver a importar
vino y agua georgiana
¡Pero no os equivoquéis!
Georgia sigue muy lejos de la esfera de
influencia rusa. Sí, es cierto, desde 2013,
Georgia ha vuelvo a comerciar con Rusia. Pero
no son su único socio comercial. Atentos.
La Unión Europea firma un acuerdo
de libre comercio con Georgia
¡Exacto! Georgia comercia a la vez con Rusia
y con la Unión Europea. Eso explica no sólo
el despegue de sus vinos, que cada vez se
exportan más. También explica la creación de
un nuevo sector económico que hace décadas
era impensable en este país. El turismo.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando ¿Turismo?
¿Quién se iría de vacaciones a un país que
está en guerra? Pues fijaos en esta gráfica:
Pues lo cierto es que, antes de la Pandemia,
Georgia llegó a tener más casi ocho millones
de visitantes. El crecimiento del
turismo ha sido casi milagroso.
Sí, es cierto que las zonas ocupadas son
peligrosas. Pero ciudades como Batumi se
han llenado de hoteles en primera línea
de costa: muchos de ellos financiados
por capital extranjero. Georgia se ha
convertido en un destino relativamente
barato para turistas rusos y turcos.
Sin embargo, no es oro todo lo que reluce.
Sí, es cierto: la Georgia de hoy en día está
mucho mejor que la hace 20 años. Sin embargo,
el país todavía mantiene un desempleo del 17%.
En la última década, apenas han invertido en
educación y, como resultado, es difícil que surjan
empresas de alto valor añadido: ¡No hay mano de
obra bien formada! Eso por no hablar de que el
sistema es cada vez más autoritario. De hecho,
en 2021 metieron a Saakashvili en la cárcel
por razones bastante oscuras. Y Rusia sigue
presionando para volver a incluir a Georgia
en su espera de influencia. Y es muy difícil
pensar que este país llegue a ser algún día
un miembro de la Unión Europea o de la OTAN.
Ahora bien, una cosa es indudable: hay muchas
lecciones que se pueden sacar de Georgia.
La pregunta es: ¿Qué puede aprender Ucrania
de Georgia? ¿Es posible que la parte Oeste de
Ucrania se convierta en una economía modélica que
atraiga inversiones? ¿Veremos un boom del turismo
en Kiev? ¿Pueden surgir industrias innovadoras
en Ucrania... pese a estar en una guerra con
Rusia? Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios. Como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí,
en VisualPolitik, sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas así que suscribíos a este canal y
dadle a la campanita para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado
este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en
el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta pronto.